okay
for people who are joining this live
stream this is
a meeting about incremental language
development for wolfen language
and uh we are heading towards some
uh release of version 12.2 so
there will start probably to be more of
these meetings and about all sorts of
things
we have a variety of topics today let's
start with new properties in axiomatic
theory
okay so let's remind ourselves um and i
had sent in
some things that i had looked at with
mano but let's remind ourselves what
um wait a minute we first of all we
talked about having a data set
um things so we want to have something
where we say something like this
the axioms this is the default but i
think we want right now we don't have
any way
of um asking for everything
right right that's correct so okay so
first thing we need is data set which is
going to work the same way that data set
for
um uh for entities works
by the way is it obvious oh i see the
reason
that we don't want axiomatic theory to
be an entity property system
is that we also have this whole operator
adventure here right so these are
parameterized entities
yes does anybody have an opinion on
whether we should in fact move this to
an entity property framework
because i mean we do have parameterized
entities like that is anybody here from
who
knows about that stuff for example
function spaces
uh how does that how do those work
so like lp spaces we'll have uh the
standard names a list
and have a formal symbol for p
and then you can do replacements and the
properties
change accordingly
i mean i do kind of like having the
saxomatic theory head but
it does seem like this will fit in
better with the energy property
framework
jose do you have an opinion about this
well
the fact that the third line takes
theory comma property it's imitating
that
but it's true that we don't have an
entity head around things we could add
it
and keep axiomatic theory yeah that's a
reasonable suggestion
when we designed these we were thinking
whether this should be actual axiomatic
theory data
and i don't remember right now the
arguments but we decided not to go that
route
right i think it was because of that
second argument
but it's not really a second argument
it's like an extended first argument
oh i see i see it i'm sorry yes
is jonathan here does he remember um
no he's not here
was he invited he was not
we should probably invite him since this
is his function
somebody see if they can track him down
please yeah sure
i can do it okay
um this is again the same pattern of
we were discussing last week for
projections and calendars
of having a named thing and then an
association in the second argument
which we added last week for projections
and calendars
or in a sublet um in a list um we were
discussing both things
and since then i have been thinking
quite a lot about it
and the converting the list of rules
into an association of rules
it's very easy and i find it useful
converting the whole thing into an
association
i'm having doubts okay so are you
supporting for the calendar thing
something like this package of name
comma
association is that right yes but not
the
pattern you should use go ahead yes we
discussed a second possibility which was
that even the theory
would be inside the association with
some theory name
something like that but but i think the
theory name from the
options are very different so they
deserve being treated differently
all right fine which is what you want to
do for calendars as well is what you're
basically saying
exactly yes right then then fine then
let's make this a pattern for other
things too
um okay let me look at um
i had done some stuff when i was talking
to mano
uh where is that stuff um should be in
working materials
axiom systems one maybe
okay so these were some things that um
we discussed uh a data set we talked
about notable theorems we talked about
now i've
i put in some more notable theorems for
boolean algebra right
yes and those have been added already to
the system that they are in prof2
okay yes um by the way ian detected some
small
errors some name which what which one
was it again
always true always always dropping true
and always dropping false
yes that's worth reversals
terrible thank you for noticing
um okay so this was some
okay so one of the issues is what are we
using for the operators like
the the not operator or the um um this
is well in this particular case
okay one of the issues is
we need some more meaningless operators
right does anybody know how to install
those we haven't installed those in
years
do you know what i'm talking about yes
yes like secret circle times and this
type of thing
yes um yes those can be added and for
example we are adding
a new one in that direction for romance
combinators
what is roman doing with combinators
yes so he wanted um how is it called
combinator apply oh yeah yeah
oh gosh i need to know about that
because i'm trying to write this blog
post you know
it's 100th anniversary of combinators in
december um
we're trying to write something about
that and we've been tracking down the
mysterious history of moses sean finkel
creator of
combinators we have had great success we
it looks like
we're actually finding um um
um yeah we're actually finding some
information which is a surprise
in the in the um bizarre
archives of both hilbert's archives and
in the archives in ukraine
anyway okay that's my somebody yeah okay
never mind
um okay
so one question is as we convert these
things
like you know we've got only a limited
inventory of meaningless operators
i don't think negation is very happily
as square
but there's a limited number of prefix
operators we have
you know meaningless prefix operators
are making sense
yep so something we could use to here is
inactive
so negation goes to inactive of not
things like that so it will print
correctly
interesting idea
i mean i like though
for something like this i don't want to
have nand in here i like having the the
dot here
um but i think um
yeah that is an interesting idea is
there nothing is there anything that
goes wrong with using an active for
those things
no i don't think so oh i'll tell you
something a problem
the problem is that when you state the
theorems
that you're trying to prove the
propositions you're trying to prove you
have to have the same operators in there
and that's a nuisance
well i mean that if i'm trying to prove
you know
a dot b equals i mean with this right
i'm going to say
find equational proof um
um of this
but i i've now got to put in i'm going
to say
p i mean p you know i've got i've got to
have the same operator
right in my um and if it's some
you know if it's a whole elaborate thing
with um
um you know having to find that operator
that's a big nuisance
um yes we would have to write manually
in the theorem uh inactive of
nand
um or do some kind of post-processing
to check that you know if you've used
operators that already exist in the
theorem
then just inactive them
it may be too late because yeah it may
have just evaluated
it may have evaluated but that that
should only happen for theorems that are
kind of trivially true
right it's it's a bit dangerous because
you never know
whether something is going to
pre-evaluate
things like and not do do already things
what the heck is this
so we're this is the parametrized entity
for function space is there a print form
for this
yep
that's kind of magnificent
what is this this entity i see this is a
parametrized name
of an entity that works like this
well i think that's a good thing to use
for these axiomatic theories as well
but i think we should you know we should
continue to advertise it through
axiomatic theory
but if we can hook it up to the entity
property system that
that would be a good thing um
all right so and look what we need to
get
as mano goes through these different
um theories she should aggregate
you know what the different operators
that would be convenient to have
are and then we can do one pass trying
to add
i mean basically at this point we could
add any unicode character
okay we're going to need two things so
so just to understand what that's what
that's
we haven't as i say we haven't added
things for this for like
probably 20 years i mean at least not
significant numbers of them
okay so this is this
is a character name page
and it maps to a certain unicode
character and
that's the important line is interpreted
by default as
blah blah blah and then it needs a
precedence as well
makes sense associativity and various
things
right one thing that would be nice as a
general solution to this problem would
be extending formal symbols to also
include operators
you're asking for an arbitrary parser
that's hard
right because what you want is an infix
look
there is a way to do it okay so this is
another way to do it
is that we could be using things like
you know something
very people very rarely use but this
form here
because you want something in fix right
jonathan
uh yes
maybe but perhaps jonathan is talking
about a formal
knot which will typeset exactly like not
perhaps with that dot done
right exactly right i mean i i don't see
why it's more complicated to have
formal plus than it is to have formal a
no it isn't it isn't but the point is
jonathan what's really needed is
theories for which we don't have a
built-in concept
like you know meets and join we don't
really have formal concepts for those or
successor
we don't have a we don't have an
existing concept for that
you see what i'm saying like for
can we have wedge and v we do have
version
wedge and v um
but but my point is there are going to
be theories for which we do not have the
operator
sure but but that's not that's not an
argument against having formal operators
that formal operators will make that
easier no i know but the other point is
that
the point that i'm trying to make in
these axiomatic theories is
look i mean axiomatic theory is already
confusing enough for people
the concept that this thing is known to
be
nand for example which isn't even true
could be nor as well is super confusing
right for a theory where there is only
one meaningful
assignment for an operator you can do
one thing but i think in many of these
there isn't so to speak i'm trying to
avoid the idea that it actually
is the plus operator like you know take
piano arithmetic
right we know it isn't necessarily
actually the plus operator it could be a
you know
a non-standard arithmetic plus operator
that makes sense jonathan well yeah but
in each case there will be a canonical
operator
so i i still don't understand why that's
an argument against having formal
operators
well what would it look like i mean
you're saying a plus sign with a dot
underneath it
right and how would you enter it formal
plus
slightly backslash yeah but backslash
plus probably doesn't even exist
it doesn't it's just the ascii character
yeah but backslash a doesn't exist
either
but that doesn't stop us supporting
formal a well fair enough
aliases like escape
dollar yeah yeah yeah right and we can
certainly do that
my question is i thought i still don't
see how this is much better than
inactive plus which will be
then understood by many other things in
the system
yes i agree
now the thing is that we don't have a
nice way to introduce inactive of plus
and perhaps that's the thing we should
try to find out
what do you mean like again
imagine that we have escape i plus
and that's inactive of plus
sure interesting
but then
you're proposing that we potentially
even change the defaults
for the exact semantic systems to be in
active operators
but you see but look take a look at take
a look at this case for example
right what are you going to put in for
that operator
no i i wasn't going that far it just
in case the user wants to use something
that reminds him of what
this is for example some users have
complained that isomatic theory
does not know information about plus and
times they want to do proofs with
arithmetic
now if we had those action systems for
arithmetic operators
it might be nice to have that type
setting
all right well okay so one possibility
then is that the second argument what
we're saying is that there
are multiple choices for the operator
assignments
right there's default choice for
operator assignments but we might have a
secondary choice for operator
assignments
that is you know i mean in this case
here we could have a secondary choice
or at least we just allow the user to
say plus goes to
yeah we already allow that but your
argument before was that then it's
difficult to write the actual
um theorems because well but if they put
it in then they then they know what
they're signing up for
right yeah that's true go ahead
at least for all of the action systems
that i've implemented so far the
um axiomatic theory already provide in
if you request out the operator
information
it already provides an interpretation of
everything in terms of operators that
currently exist in the language
what does that have like if you ask
axiomatic theory ball from axiom's
operators it will tell you that nand is
interpreted
that sentence author to be interpreted
as the nand operator
and that's right that's that that's this
thing here that i feel right
my point is in each of those
associations the left-hand side is a
specification of a built-in wall from
language symbol
there has not yet been a case i i i
agree we shouldn't preclude the
possibility that it will happen there
will be a case
there will be a question because there
is standard notation for it
right but successor for example we don't
have a standard notation for successor
but what do you have there on the left
is string
yes yes right right but but but the
string is
at least reminiscent of a standard
language name
right but we would have perfectly a
string successor
sure that's right that's why that's why
we put it in as a string because we knew
that that was going to happen
all right so the issue is what is the
default right hand side there
is the default right hand side center
dot or is it something that looks like
this
nan goes to inactive of nand
that will be another possibility right
and so if i look at that if i say
axiomatic theory
um
that would be a nice auto complete to by
the way be able to have
devon if you can report that
yeah inactive doesn't typeset nicely
in data sets
or indeed in summary boxes
uh that should be fixed that's about
exactly that's fixable
right which means that right now if you
if you try and use find equation proof
within an active operator it will look
pretty ugly
okay well can we get that fixed i mean
that seems like a rapid fix
thing um
okay uh so i mean that doesn't look bad
except that i don't like the fact that
it's an actual operator there
hum and group theory we definitely don't
have you know what is the right thing to
represent group multiplication it's not
a time sign for sure
i'm also worried about some of these
things with built-in associativity
and commutativity actually some of these
operators have built-in
yeah well the inactive version of of
nand does not right it doesn't have its
built-in
communicativity correct
all right look go ahead we have small
circle
i know i know i know but but notice that
small circle isn't
a built-in thing so i mean what we have
in the group axioms right if i
ask for the group gap group axioms here
and then i say operators yeah we don't
use small circle
by the way we should switch around that
autocomplete so it comes operators first
before operator
we use circle times right i did just
i just just circle a small circle it's
probably the right thing
an identity what is that creature that's
an over-tilde one
hmm
well it might be better to use some um
the problem is we can't change this too
much because people are going to start
having code
that assumes a particular you know
operator
because they're going to just say find
equational proof with group axioms
and it'll assume the operator
we might be able to get away it's still
pegged as experimental we might be able
to get away with changing it one time
here
and i do tend to kind of agree with you
that small circle will be better for
this
or even just dot center dot might be
better
well so let's make a decision on that
um
i i would say center dot what do you
think jonathan
yeah it's no it's not bad
um okay
all right so let's come back here to all
right so i think what we want to do
is potentially
what i'm thinking is we might want to
have a secondary thing here
that says um
i mean that kind of thing where that
basically is bank switching
um
you know i'm saying that that that would
maybe we have another property called
um inactive function
operators
that basically is this form as much as
we can make it
within active operators rather than with
these arbitrary symbols
does that make sense to people
yeah we can do that we would give an
error for the cases in which we don't
have the
corresponding well we'd say
not available for would we use
permutation product for the group case
what are permutation products
we have a symbol permutation product the
hell is that
it's something you can multiply to
permutations right
has its own symbol oh my gosh
you know the problem is what we're
dealing with here is
you know how yes i suppose we would do
that because permutation
product would actually work between
group elements wouldn't it
yeah you had a concrete group element
group elements you could actually do
this
so okay fine so that would be the and
what about for the inverse then
we have permutation inverse or inverse
as a function as a function yes but not
as a piece of symbolism
yeah type sets as permutation power
minus one
well but maybe that's useful to people i
mean if they want something which is
actually the inactive functions
why not give them that inverse arrow
that permutation power thing
that seems like a reasonable idea
actually because that way
what you can do is you can take any
formula you have and you can convert it
to a formula in terms of our
semantically defined operators
and you just say activate and kaboom the
formula evaluates
right
yeah it may be useful to check examples
for example
yes well so maybe there's a different
name that we gave as the second argument
here
um
what should it be called i mean it's a
version where
no it's okay actually inactive functions
as that second argument there
um okay
all right where am i saving this by the
way um
you have a folder in your notes called
axiomatic theory
okay
um
all right so let's go over here now okay
so we've got inactive function operators
all right so let's keep going here
by the way sorry just just a quick thing
do we not have a slight
philosophical issue with essentially
interpreting every group as a
permutation group
um perhaps but that's the only type of
group we can handle right now
so we don't have functionality for
matrix groups this is exactly the
slippery slope that we're going down
here because the same thing as
non-standard arithmetic
right that these are purely formal axiom
systems
right this is kind of my issue right i
mean so i know you know obviously we
have kaylee's theorem and so it's a
reasonable interpretation to think of
the
to think of these things as permutation
groups but that's implicitly assuming
that the group is acting on its own set
of elements
which won't be true for a general formal
group
so i see this as representing some sort
of model
so you have the general theory and then
you want to play with examples
and then you fall back to some
potentially bigger theory
okay look but but the the choice of i
don't know
my view is that the choice of operators
should not imply a particular model
yes but unfortunately that's what we
have okay
jonathan this is the logic okay if
you've got like circle times it means
nothing
it implies no model right as soon as you
put
in there in active nand it implies a
model
right right there you know whatever you
know stone's theorem or whatever it's
called
you're just dealing with the standard
boolean algebra thing not
the two to the n sized algebra right no
i
i
agree which is so i think what we should
do is this i think we should say
exomatic theory
and then inactive function model let's
say
actually i mean in general the right
thing to do is to name the model
right so there might be a default model
and by model
all we're doing is we're filling in
function names that correspond to
in fact look the obvious way to do this
is
to say um to say
essentially typical models
and then to say or or
standard model
or standard model operators
right exactly because we're not defining
a model we don't have a domain of
discourse
we're just we're defining part of a
model
right so so the standard model operators
would then be
this is so weird i mean so we would have
nand
goes to inactive nand
right or in the group case we you can
argue about what you want to do with the
group case
um so then
what we would do here is we would say
something like
uh somebody's commenting on our live
stream
that standard model means something in
physics yes yes that's an amusing thing
the oh boy um
you know the real question is will there
come a time
when in our interpretation of rule space
the standard model is the standard model
okay jonathan at least should have found
that amusing
yeah i do wonder at what point will the
standard model be an axiom system in
axiomatic theory
right right that's the um
uh and then how long will it be when it
is
right um the okay but in any case i
think the right thing to do here
this is a nice idea i think you give the
axiom system and then you potentially
give the model here
and in a sense by giving the operator
assignments
that is a version of defining the model
perhaps the the property that you wrote
there
none goes to an active nand we could
store that as nand goes to nand
and it's when they are inserted that the
inactive automatically gets
there because the model the model
doesn't
care about inactive i
see
so well how does it know when to insert
it no not there i'm referring to the
line
five lines below oh i see
i see in this line here exactly so the
model
doesn't care about inactive it's when
you are going to replace
the internal operators that it does care
okay fine so then then what would happen
here is
um okay here's what i suggest
i suggest that we say symbolic
the the default is either symbolic model
or just symbolic and then we also have
standard model
and the standard model works like this
but it should be symbolic model
operators not stan
not symbolic model um no i'm saying for
the second argument here
for the second element here right but
unless we're defining a domain of
discourse it's not a model
at best we're defining an infinite
family of models
and we can't define domain and discourse
unless we define types
presumably i think that's a bit too much
jonathan so
for example for permutations we just
consider all possible permutations there
is no
need to specify a degree in the system
we can multiply permutations of
different degree
or for numbers we just consider all
numbers we don't have to say i'm working
with these numbers
but that's you're still implicitly
assuming you know
in in the numbers case right that your
your domain of discourse is all numbers
yes but i think that's implicit in the
operator once you say i'm using plus
you know what which numbers you are
using or
once you say permutation product you
know which permutations you are using
those supported by permutation product
and you say nand knows that it is expect
boolean operators and things
you know true and false and so on
exactly
in a sense we have type by documentation
or type by implementation if you want
it's
what the function supports i i see your
point okay
so this is the the the domain of the
function is the domain of this course
just implicitly
exactly okay okay so then the two things
that we would
usually support are standard model
so this would be um
and then we could have another thing
called
model operators or model
notable models
now for group theory we could start
listing groups here
and then we would say you know standard
model
arrow and then we've got
the basically the mapping from our name
for the operators to
the name that is going to be used there
see what i'm saying
and then so then you could type in well
for maxim's comma
some the default will be symbolic model
but you could also say standard model
there
i think this works so that's irrelevant
the inactive functions that model is
irrelevant
now operators here
would presumably that that will give it
relative to the
model that you are referring to okay now
but these names on the left-hand side
are purely i mean honestly that name
isn't really right
for bullying algebra what is that name
for bullying algebra really
unfortunately that is right because
because otherwise we have the and or
or not a boolean algebra so that's what
we have to do for boolean algebra
so that's fine okay all right make sense
to everybody
let's move on um
everybody good here mano you understand
i i think so um i'll i'll loop back with
jose as well
but um what what about the syntax for
the properties we already discussed
like the citation for example yeah let's
go through that
um
okay axiom names that's the next can of
worms
how to deal with that so let's let's
pick um let's look at the group axioms
for example
well actually let's do what what's a
good example where the field axioms
don't they have names
what you chose precisely the one that
should not be there we remove those
because they were not expressible via
equational logic but now they should be
expressible in jonathan's extension so
we can now handle implies right so
all right so there so some of those
axioms have names correct
i think they can be named okay fine but
so how do we deal with
um
look maybe what we should do i mean one
thing we could do is simply say
we could have a property called named
axioms
in which we repeat the axioms but with
their names
or we could say axiom names and we could
either do something
where we okay what do we want to do here
we could have something which is in
parallel to this list
we could have something where this list
is repeated but with names what do we
want to do
it suggests to name a property that
returns an association with named
actions and the values are the actions
themselves
i don't know whether it should be named
actions or actions association
like we do in entity property value
association
i see where it where this thing now is a
named version where this were just the
axioms
the one property is just the axioms
yeah there we go ax seems that's a good
idea i like that idea axioms association
um i like that idea
and then we'll name the axioms with with
sort of standard
uh you know things like this now
um the only issue then is common names
for the axioms if you want to make a
table for example
how do you do that
well i can imagine that some actions
will be obvious like commutativity
associativity etc
others we will have to decide and try to
yes no i know but i mean look
de morgan law de morgan law
one blah blah blah let's say okay
that's not usually an axiom but but it's
going to look like that it's going to be
much more
of an entity-like thing
now look if these were entities if every
axiom was an entity
then we're home free then we've got a
common name property for the entity
you are thinking of actions that appear
in various
action systems no i was thinking of just
naming i was thinking of
actually entitifying the individual
axioms in an axiom system
in addition to entertifying look one
thing we could do is we could have an
entity um axiomatic system
ring axims
then we could have an entity
axiom
standard name ring distributivity
or something and then that
would get to be that would get to have a
name
you know would would show up as an act
as an entity and then you could ask for
its common name and then you've got its
common name
see what i'm saying this is the right
way to do it i'm afraid
it's to make all these things into
entities because then then
then what we've got if we did that
i i seem to recall when we were first
designing axiomatic theory and we
discussed the possibility of having it
be
an entity store the argument for not
doing that was precisely
because we wanted to be able to do
operator overrides and things like that
well the operator overrides thing um ian
has convinced me that there's another
solution to that
that it's possible to have parameterized
entities which it wasn't possible
then when we designed this okay
then make the whole thing an entity
store
i don't think this works in entity store
which works the parameterized entities
that's a custom parameterized entity
yeah that's through wolfram alpha
i don't think you can have lists to
standard names in a
entity store so i think the question
here is whether
in this list comma association that we
were planning before
perhaps it's only the string in the
first argument that should be an entity
it's the abstract thing who cares
logically about
which names we are using for the
operators
no i'm not suggesting the operators be
be entities i'm suggesting
this thing be an entity and i'm
suggesting that the
naming the axioms i mean in other words
if we did
entities for axioms then we could for
individual axioms
then we could do something else that
would be quite nice which is to just be
able to put in a single axiom
rather than a whole axiom system into
axiomatic find equational proof
so i'm saying if we had something called
entity axiom ring distributivity that
just becomes
an axiom which you could feed in and
will get translated into whatever that
axiom is
for um
and and you know maybe what we do is we
say if you want to
parametrize this axiom in a different
way you can say
for now at least axiomatic theory of
that entity
axiom blah blah blah
comma and then the operator assignments
that's a way so what i was suggesting is
to do the same thing for the action
theories
so the fact that the operator
assignments are outside the entity
always yes i think that's fine
i'm i'm sold on that idea but then then
what i'm suggesting is that in the end
axioms association
that what we do is to use the entities
for axioms for the axiom names
see what i'm saying right
but
we still use strings for the
um we're still using strings for the
operator names i mean we could have
a thing called group theory
multiplication that is an you know
an entity there but i think we shouldn't
bother
what do you think yeah okay
okay fine all right okay so then we've
we've come with those okay so now
so that that gives us a solution for
axiom names so mano is making up
you know our kind of standard name names
for the
axioms um which we should you know
should make up a list we can check them
off
okay description
okay i think that should be an
english language description of what
this axiom system is
you know like in this case it would say
minimal axioms for boolean algebra
okay so that might be um
i don't know whether i'm not putting
this here okay so other properties
okay so description if anybody
anybody object to this i think that
should just say you know minimal axioms
for boolean algebra
you know and we could say things like
you know
hilbert's
1923
axiom system for geometry or something
i don't know what it would be whatever
it is you know things like that the
thing that identifies them for
with them within the mathematics
literature makes sense
yep okay reference now
ian i think we have a standardized way
with with our
with our upcoming bibliographic
reference system
we will have a nice canonical way to do
this but until that's the case what are
we doing
for references in other mathematical
structure things
i i don't know 50
wait does ian know i
think it's all over the place like in
the geometric scene
entities we just have strings with
for what for like formulation sources
okay so so tell me what tell me the name
of one of those so geometric scene
and then what um do pythagorean theorem
why does this not auto complete
okay and now what do i do the property
you want is formulation sources
that's that's really bad
unprocessed arrow false what the heck is
that what is nested grid
what on earth is this this is garbage
this is supposed to be a list of strings
i'll look into this
supposed to just be the string euclid
elements book one proposition 47 300 bc
okay well this is kind of cruddy okay so
um i don't know the status of the
michael allen project
to do bibliographic symbolic
bibliographic citations
okay um but we should make
something which can fit into that future
system
okay so mano should find out what is
done on that system already
and should put things in here which are
in that format
probably as associations and we'll just
use the raw association for now and
later on we'll have the wrapped
association
make sense
okay then i think we want um
uh a question on a live stream
from pamela's perhaps not the original
permanentes
is the equational logic the same as
dijkstra's equation of logic i have no
idea does jonathan no i didn't know
dexter even worked on those kinds of
things i think there's only one kind of
equation of logic but i don't really
know
um there are multiple a bit like with
first order logic there are multiple
systems that are
characterized by different um you know
inference rules like the hilbert system
and other kinds of things
so yes the the answer is the fine
equation proof uses the dijkstra
scholten
inference rules for equational logic
okay um okay formulation date
just a date object
uh or missing unknown or whatever
um this just be part of reference
no it shouldn't be because you wanted uh
you want to do things like make
um dateless plots of things so
it will be part of the reference but it
will also be
it should also be separated um
um
for these axiom systems i kind of think
that we should do
should we do author formulation author
it's now a very platonic question
whether these things have authors or
whether they just exist in the world
so in geometric scene we call these
formulators
there's also like provers
proof sources proof dates there may be
other distinctions you want to make
yeah it makes sense to distinguish
formulator improver
what the hell does it mean to prove an
axiom system
right it may not mean anything for this
i think it means nothing
okay this one i suspect
that essentially all of our formulators
will be
entities but they're all well-known
enough characters to be entities
um so they should be people entities i
think
um okay so now
okay so having defined this the other
things we need to talk about
uh are axiom schemas which i think
jonathan has an idea about
and also um
[Music]
well anything else that's come up let's
take a look down here
without wanting to derail the
conversation too much if we're going to
start
supporting model stuff in axiomatic
theory
it may be worth discussing how this
overlaps with the model stuff i did for
counter examples
because it would be nice to have that be
consistent what is counterweight
what is counter examples so actually i
can i can email you this
so we discussed this a while ago but it
never got it it's not currently in the
build but there's a
um
okay i've just sent you some code
i just run it yeah if you run that and
then if you run
i don't know something like
this so you know this is a
this is trying to prove a theorem that
is false
in this case trying to show that the
nand operator has associativity
and so the way you want to demonstrate
that that's false is by finding the next
counter example so we never finalized
the design which is why it never it
didn't make it into the kernel but so
find equation might be an interesting
thing for manu to work on too
yeah yeah sure right i i'm happy to
relinquish control of this
but um okay so if you call counter
if you ask for counter example
association
it will show you the explicit
multiplication table and the counter
example
association
and example should be lowercase
oh boy
um and you can also call there's a bunch
of things you can do so you can also
call falsification function
which will confirm to you that it is in
fact a valid counter example
okay i understand that's nice all right
we should we should nail this design as
well i mean
the main point of discussion was whether
this should be find the question of
proof itself
that runs two parallel processes and one
find
one trying to find a proof and one
trying to find a counter example and
returns
whatever finds first or whether this
needs a separate function
because one of the main problems in find
the question of proof
is that it may hang trying to find a
proof
while there is none and so if it was
running simultaneously
a search for a counterexample it might
stop once it finds one
yeah i agree is that right jonathan i
mean in other words because i've got
some things i'm trying to run
right now where maybe i should be trying
to run a parallel counter example
checker yeah i mean for instance if you
take that specification
of that theorem and run find equational
proof on it i'm pretty sure it will hang
i'm almost positive
well it will eventually time out uh no
time time constraint is infinity by
default
you know this is girdle's theorem in
action
somehow right right but the example
finding stuff if
you know as long as the counter example
is reasonably small it's pretty
efficient
um i the other yeah i mean jose is right
so the two main design problems that we
ran
into were figuring out whether this
should be part of fine equation or proof
and how that should work
um and also figuring out i think you had
some
you basically wanted us to be more
certain about that about how we were
representing models
as a general design thing okay but this
counter example thing putting it in to
find equation of proof
that seems like an obvious win right
right with overrides obviously
yes and i mean what it should do is come
back with missing
you know not true more or less
right so right now we're writing a
failure object
okay fine failure yes
okay like if you do hang on
let me construct an example
yeah so like if you do this
will return a failure
so i guess the yeah the point would be
that that we'd have three
failure modes rather than two
well proposition false is is this is a
failure mode but but then
one could have a thing that says that as
an opener here that actually gives the
counter example
in the summary box yes right
right well i would say that once we find
a way to express the counter example
it would be nicer if we return a counter
example object
it's more useful to keep working with it
later
yeah well i think if you ask for a proof
look a proof is not account i mean
what is the point here well look a
counter example is a proof it's just a
proof of the opposite thing you are the
the thing you asked for
that that's weird can we put this
counter example thing into the
into the function repository for now
could you package it
i can yeah i can turn it into a function
repository entry if you want
i think that'll be a good idea i mean in
terms of the design
um we should get a better icon
that icon is meaningless
but i thought it was some kind of uh
i don't know i was thinking some kind of
mycenaean
never mind the stupid i i think i made
it because i wanted it to be i wanted to
make a cross as a graph but i
picked the wrong graph layout oh
that's a oh that's amusing okay the all
right but so
here
why don't if this was an association
i mean you're pointing out that
axiomatic theory could have some other
models
that are explicit models
right right so i guess yeah the point
i'm making is that in this we are
i have implicitly introduced a kind of
way of
introducing a model right that it's a
list that contains
uh you know operator arrow and then a
multiplication table
as a you know stated as a pure function
and the question is
is that a design we want to stand behind
or should we modify it for
maximum well notice that what you've
done here is you've picked the name of
the operator
as the left-hand side whereas here it's
the
it's the name of the operator it's the
it's the in
it it's the sort of it's the it's the
tag of the operator right which is the
left-hand side here
whereas here in counter-example it's the
actual operator symbol
whereas in axiomatic theory it's the
string name
right well i don't think that's bad
except i wouldn't do it as a
i would say operator i mean um
i would say you know something like
operator models
arrow
santa dart arrow now you know the arity
right
and these are always finite models is
that true
yes
and actually yeah the algorithm wouldn't
work if it were if the model will not
find it
well i'm thinking this should be
operator multiplication tables
or just operated tables
and then this could be
a
symbol
or variable settings
i mean we know it's a counter example
because you just asked for a counter
example
except if if we do what jose is
proposing then we haven't just asked for
a counter example
well but i know but we're returning it
inside a counter example object
right so then we know it's a counter
example
i think that's reasonable why don't you
make a wfr that works this way
okay uh
i'm not even sure it needs the counter
example object for now for the wfr case
i would just return the association
okay you don't think that having the
falsification function i i don't know i
thought that was a nice gimmick
what does it do uh you can try it it it
it's like you know it's the it's the
duel of the proof function
so if you run it it should say false
i understand that's nice
um
all right i'm sold on having i am
fine i'm sold on having the counter
example object okay
um hopefully with a less dopey icon
yeah i don't know why these are colony
clauses
why aren't they just equals this they
should all be equals i think
okay uh even the center dot
i think so let's just put a function
right i mean
and then yeah so that you just take the
operator tables
and put the you know hash hash next to
them
and do you do that thing
right um
okay okay all right let me just raise
one other thing
groups i may be totally muddled here
but how do we take the defining
relations for a group and stick them in
to the axiomatic systems stuff
there is annotation for that um
so it's like somatic theory you have the
axomatic theory group actions coma
quaternion
that should return both the
the actions of group theory plus the
actions
with the defining relations of
quaternion
and it's possible to choose the names of
the generators too so that's not just a
generic group
exactly you can prove things about the
quotation group
oh cool okay and the and there is
another property that allows you to say
generators goes to i comma j
okay so hold on hold on here can i put
in alternating group five or something
uh you need the find the question
sorry the group theory the final group
data annotation which is
list alternative group comma five but i
can update it too yeah you should update
it maybe mana could help with that too
absolutely
alternating group comma five list
oh i did not know this worked that's
really nice yeah
it was added for 12 1. okay is it
consistent with our models idea it sort
of is
right it's sort of a model i mean
in in particular we could potentially
hear
i mean let me understand the
relationship to this 2.3 dot i mean
in addition to defining relations we
should say
oh gosh the notation for these defining
relations relative to over here
what does that what am i how am i
understanding that
yes so each of these numbers represents
a generator
and so in in axiomatic theory they get
names that are variables so two will be
f three will be g etc
um so for example let's let's read the
first one so two times three
will be f times g times two
is f and then three minus one is is
center sorry
sorry sorry sorry hold on wait a minute
three
when when you say i mean the one means
the identity is that correct
yes okay so two and three is arbitrary
other elements is that correct
well imagine that the eight elements of
the quaternion group are called one to
eight
and so you ask for the multiplication
table
and you get an 8x8 multiplication table
corresponding to the elements one to
eight
so in that multiplication table if we
just select the second and third rows
those are going to act as the generators
okay it's so synchronized and so
the problem is that in axiomatic theory
to avoid
having names we use letters like we do
with all other
variables so f and g will represent
respectively two and three
and the convention in in final group
data
is that all the generating relations are
equated to the identity
while in the in this case no i
understand that but i mean
f and g it doesn't know f and g and a
and b
from a hole in the ground right i could
call i could name this anything i want
exactly and you can say in the same way
that we can name the
operators you can say generators goes to
list a and
a a and j and they will be called a and
j
but i mean if i try and prove a theorem
can i name them a and b
here or will that confuse things why
does it no no no
it doesn't care because they i mean
that's why we have formal a to avoid
confusion with
a yeah understand but these similarly
this could instead of f and g i could
use formal a and b here
in these relations correct right
it won't conflict with any of the others
because those are quantified
right
i think you shouldn't it's a bit
confusing to read
i see so these are the the defining
relations are not quantified
exactly because they are explicit
elements
oh boy well that
raises another can of worms right
because i mean that's in addition to the
model
the model is about i mean this is
jonathan's domain of discourse thing the
model is about the operators
the domain of discourse is about what
the actual these symbols actually mean
right and um this is
something else we should arguably
discuss so in in axiomatic theory
our philosophy was that the
you know the literal elements like say
the identity element in group theory
those are treated as being like
operators with arity zero
yes which implicitly is what axiomatic
theory well
if you prove a theorem using the uh
group axioms for the quaternions
that's implicitly how fine equation
proof is treating f and g
right we have an example in the exomatic
theory page if you want to look at it
it's the second application example
you know we thought we were going now a
very straightforward project here
it isn't okay no matter um go ahead
second application example yep
is this documented this thing with
groups i
think it is yeah we discussed it
certainly for i didn't read i'm just
i'm incapable of reading that's my
problem um
so go to the second one further down
yeah here and you see how generators are
named inj
at the end
yes yes i do hmm
interesting well that's not totally
silly how that works
and by the way gratifyingly the
association is sufficiently similar that
this is easily interconvertible with the
multi-way algebra
stuff wow
it's moving into place the grand
unification of everything from the
standard model of physics to the
standard model
of whatever to yeah cool
um
okay well i think this is a reasonable
place to go then
is to say you add these um
um i do think by the way you should have
above the fold you should have at least
one example with group theory
here above the fold okay
okay what are we going to do so mano is
going to work through
sort of standard axiomatic theories and
it's then going to work on
presumably things like
okay we've got axiom schemas which
jonathan needs to define how that's
going to work
and then
well then we've got a sort of infinite
collection so we've got logic puzzles
which go ahead so just one quick thing i
mean so the
the way that okay the the design that i
think we came up with for
doing the axiom schemas kind of relies
on this interpretation of
uh sort of explicit elements as being
operators of arity zero because what
that means is
when you're quantifying you know in in
something when you say you know for all
abc
center dot a whatever um those
abcs are not treated as being
ontologically different
to the actual to the center dots it's
just the center dots have a narrative
two and the abcs have a narrative zero
and so because of that there's nothing
to stop you also from quantifying over
the operators
because center dot and a are treated as
being as i say sort of ontologically the
same kind of thing
yes um and so and as soon as you as soon
as we have
a sort of a reasonable way of doing that
then we immediately have you know have
support for higher order logics
right which is but that's not the same
thing i mean that's a different branch
than the axiom schemas issue
why how are axiom schemas made from
quantification over functions
that's what i mean that's what an axiom
schema is right you know
something like the induction axiom you
can formulate it either as an axiom
schema in first order logic or as a
single axiom in second order logic
because you're you're quantifying over
uh um
predicates all right let's take a look
at this for all b
this is kind of messy but but um so
you're saying
so how what is induction if you if you
write it in second order logic
well if in second or logic then you're
just
um you're just quantifying over the set
of possible predicates
yes well that's nice that's a clean way
to do it if we can do that
all you're saying is you know for every
phi being a unary predicate you know
such and such is true
and the axiom schema approach in first
order logic is to say we'll just have a
separate axiom for each possible phi
but you could also just say we'll have
phi be a quantified operator
and then that's a second normal logic
statement but it's a finitely
aximitizable thing
all right so your point is you can
unroll it into
a finite sequence well it's an infinite
sequence of axioms but it's a generator
there's a finite generator
of an infinite sequence of axioms in
physical logic right
so just as we could have a separate
axiom for every a b you know every
possible value of a b and c but we don't
we quantify them
we quantify over them so that's what
that's why this is a first order logic
thing rather
i like that interpretation about some
schemas yes yeah right
and i think that's yeah i think that
personally i feel like that's the
cleanest way to do it it is
very clean that's a very good idea so
what we have to do is just call it f
dot and we'll have a formal you know
formal f and we'll just say
formal f dot so i mean that that would
be
we're saying for all formal f
a b for example
f of a b you know whatever it is equals
b
or whatever the heck it is right so
that's that's fine
looks good to me that's great if we can
do if we can do axiom schemas
like that wonderful solved
that requires minimal modification of
fine equation proof
yeah that's great great now what about
logic puzzles
and are we going to represent those as
axiom systems so to speak with
crocodiles and things like this
so i think there's a strong argument for
doing that precisely because
there are so many in the in so the
examples that i gave in the
documentation were taken from this tptp
database
which have a huge number of um logic
puzzles they used for kind of
benchmarking things like
vampire
okay but but the problem is then what if
you say i mean that's okay
so long as we recognize that there's
going to be a whole boatload i mean i
suspect there's going to be like
30 or 40 you know axiomatic systems that
are sort of universal algebra like
things
then
um then they'll be you know just a
boatload of these logic
puzzles presumably
um
let's see oh wow
individual axiom sets for tptp
okay so let's pick around the maximum
set
what the heck are these
so these are generally the these things
are formulated using
the tptp language which is based in turn
on the mizar
formal language oh well let's make an
importer for that
well yeah yeah quite right i mean it
definitely seems like a good use of time
to just write a compiler for mizah into
axiomatic theory
okay
um i'm surprised nobody's done that
i did look at myself long ago and it was
easy to
interact with the first simplest
group theory theorems etc but then it
became too complicated
quickly but notice that those places
will have
like mizar will have you know named
theorems of group theory and so on
yes but they also have a tremendous
number of collections of intermediate
steps
and then they use some variant of sub
theory
what was it something called graphendiac
exactly yeah and so just the minimal
variations of things complicate things
uh
at least what i try to do so so i give
up at some point
i wonder how these compare to the
metamath
axioms which i've been playing with
well anyway so okay so the tusky growth
and deep
set theory is also implemented in
metamath
so at least at a formal level they
should be interconvertible i just don't
know how different the language is
yeah but i wonder whether they've got i
mean there's like 43 000 theorems
in metamath which i was playing around
with and i wonder whether this has more
or less or
it doesn't seem to have them collected
as well but okay so the
bunch of axiom systems and then there
are
well okay so i think nano needs to needs
to go look at these
but it seems like that's a that's a good
source there
um
syntax would be enough that's a good
sign
it's also possible i think you know
nick just did that nice work on metamath
importing
um
well if we can have an importer that
actually imports in a formal
style that can be fed into find equation
or proof that would be pretty cool
i think we can don't see why we
shouldn't be able to
all right i need to go i'm supposed to
be doing something completely different
here unfortunately um
so uh right unfortunately we didn't get
to these other things
on the agenda today um
i think we have to do that another time
but uh devin this is you know where to
find this file
and give it to mano i think nano has a
bunch of things to do here
uh should be off and running that's this
is great
um um
um fine all right
uh anything else for right now
oh okay all right see you all soon